one of the things that we hear the
Democrats always talking about is $15
minimum wage actually don't know your
policy on that well I'm for the spirit
that if you're wearing a full-time you
should not be poor but if you were to
increase the minimum wage to $15 it
would hasten the automation of all these
fast-food jobs that pay $9 there
probably is everywhere yes I pad that's
it there are there all these hardware
stores and like Main Street retailers
that are just scraping by that are
paying people nine ten bucks an hour you
take it up to 15 bucks an hour there
hundred percent gonna cut chips cut
workers it's much better just to give
everyone 1,000 bucks a month
it's an effective raise of $6 an hour
for anyone who's working full-time it
doesn't come out of the pockets of small
businesses it recognizes parents and
caregivers and nurturers that the
minimum wage does not touch and it's
actually better for small business
because is that hardware store gonna be
busier if everyone has money yes and so
instead of taking it out of this
hardware store and this is one thing
that drives me nuts about the left I
mean I've run a small company it's like
like sometimes people imagine that like
every business just must be somehow made
of money it's it's totally not the case
particularly in this era of mega
consolidation where you have these giant
companies is coming and running amuck
like they're made of money sure but it's
like the average like independent
business made of money such that you can
just say hey pay everyone fifteen bucks
an hour and it's not gonna have any
effect on what happened there that that
disconnect in the left now where they do
this with this $15 minimum wage because
I agree they sort of think that
everything is equal so that my small
business where we have you know five
full timers let's say in five
part-timers is is equal to Amazon which
they're also not thrilled with Amazon
they have too many employees I may be of
too few employees like there's always
some weird number maybe if I had 27
employees it's the exact amount that's
right but I know even right now we're
hiring interns but we're paying them
because I don't want people to work for
me Yuri I want I mean I want them to
feel good about what they're doing you
know I mean I want them to feel
incentivize and all those things but but
that concept that you just hit on there
how do we break through to that because
it seems so obvious to me you can't tell
a guy that's got a little business just
forget me just take some youtuber who's
got one
wants to bring on someone else now
there's some kid that really wants to
learn YouTube and it's like he probably
worked for free but I want to give him 8
dollars an hour to me there's nothing
wrong with that but they would literally
force you to not hire the guy yeah and
so that's again why I think this freedom
dividend is so superior because but what
I think they're there and I got what you
were thinking now but what do you like
truly this this is the disconnect that I
can't figure out like do they actually
think they're doing the right thing or
does it just sound easy so you just say
it 15 arm in wage of course why not well
yeah so I think many people have come of
age in a time when capitalism has become
so corrupt and extreme that they are
deeply skeptical businesses acting
morally which that's legitimate it's
like a lot of businesses are doing very
messed up things and so they're taking
from that it's like oh these businesses
are systemically exploiting their
workers when they have ample resources
to do so and so they're imagining that
all businesses are like Amazon they have
ample resources it's in part because
they haven't worked in like a lot of
different settings where they would
understand the distinctions between
different types of employers yeah so
you're giving them the benefit of the
doubt well you know it's like I mean the
intention the spirit is positive it's
like do I think that people who are
working full-time should not be you know
like scraping to just get by it's like
sure right you know but is that also
part of the disconnect that you because
everyone always brings this to fast food
jobs when they frame this argument and
they say $15 an hour because the average
person when fast food joint can't live
on a full-time wage and it's like but
that actually except if you're a manager
say at McDonald's or something like that
that shouldn't be you a full-time job
there's another layer of an economic
problem there right yeah there is and
McDonald's is rolling out self-serve
kiosks in every location in the country
by 2020
right now with the wage the way it is so
it's not like I mean automation is going
to come even if you do keep even if you
lowered it actually you could have the
government come in and say we have to
pay you less and they'd still be doing
it right yeah and then the question if
you're the government is like what is my
intention like is it that like no you
have to preserve that McJob it's like
well how about we just automate that job
and the question is what is that person
doing instead
and so there is this really important
evolution that we need to undergo as a
society which is to say look the market
right now is a highly imperfect
determinant of what jobs we should be
doing so if you take these people who
are working in fast-food restaurants and
these jobs get automated away like in my
mind they should be automated away and
trying to preserve those jobs is not
where we should be going but there's
also this massive gap as to what the
jobs of the future will look like it's
one reason why the freedom dividend is
so important because if you have a town
of 10,000 adults in Missouri and then
you put ten million dollars more into
their hands then you end up creating not
just more jobs in the main street but
you also end up supercharging their
religious organizations their nonprofits
their community organizations you create
different forms of opportunities for
people and that is to me the
generational challenge we're in the
midst of is trying to figure out what
the jobs of the future look like when
the market is going to try and zero out
more and more Americans very quickly
[Music]